From 1995 to 2001, Xena : Warrior Princess
delivered 134 episodes of historical fantasy
with a campy twist. In the years since its
finale, it's become a bonafide cult classic.
But what has the cast been up to over the course
of the last two decades? We're here to find out.
Though she starts out as a ruthless warrior,
Xena's arc bends towards mercy after an epiphany
leads her to seek forgiveness for the many
crimes of her past. Meeting the gentle Gabrielle,
who proves to be the perfect
counterpoint to Xena's aggression,
certainly helps — with a "good angel" in tow, Xena
wends her way towards something like redemption
over the course of the show. That's not to say she
doesn't do a whole lot of incredibly cool fighting
along the way, of course. After all, this isn't
a show called Xena: Peaceful Princess. But now,
Xena fights for those who can't defend themselves.
Over the course of the series, she takes on
evildoers of all kinds, from the pettiest warlords
to the mightiest gods, all in the name of justice.
Xena might live an active life, but so does Lucy
Lawless, the actor who played her. Since 2001,
in television and film, Lawless has racked
up an impressive collection of screen work.
She's had significant character arcs on
shows like Battlestar Galactica, The L Word,
Spartacus, Parks and Recreation, and even teamed
up with her old Xena co-star Bruce Campbell in
Ash vs. Evil Dead. As for movies, Lawless has
also been seen in small roles in Spider-Man,
EuroTrip, The Changeover, and a plethora
of television movies. Her next role will
be as the voice of Nunchuk in Minions: The
Rise of Gru, slated for a 2021 release.
Xena: Warrior Princess set a high bar for
women's representation onscreen. Take Gabrielle:
Played by Renee O'Connor, she starts her arc on
the show as a babe-in-the-woods type who tempers
Xena's bloodier instincts. But as she learns how
to fight and protect others, Gabrielle grows,
changes, and discovers entirely
new facets of herself. Eventually,
Gabrielle becomes a celebrated bard, a
skilled warrior, and an actual Amazon.
While Renee O'Connor has continued working in
television since her 134-episode run on Xena,
her career has stayed relatively low-key. O'Connor
has appeared in a number of made-for-television
movies including Last Chance, and the horror
movies Monster Ark and Alien Apocalypse. On
the big screen, O'Connor has had roles in Ghost
Town: The Movie, Boogeyman 2, Diamonds and Guns,
and Deadrise. O'Connor's most recent
screen credits are from 2017, when she
starred in the drama A Question of Faith
and the family sci-fi movie Watch the Sky.
If you're surprised by the seeming scarcity of
roles on her resume, don't be — it's only because
O'Connor has shifted from working on the screen
to the stage. She's been in productions of Annie,
Uncle Vanya, Mary Poppins, and Romeo
and Juliet over the last few years,
earning tremendous acclaim along the way. Sure,
it might be weird to imagine sweet Gabrielle as
the fearsome Lady Macbeth, but O'Connor's
skill is more than enough to make it work.
While Lucy Lawless and Renee O'Connor
star in every episode of Xena,
Ted Raimi's Joxer the Mighty only appears in
43 episodes. This might come as a surprise
to even the most seasoned Xena fan, such
is the strength of Raimi's performance.
"Xena!"
"Yeah?"
"Joxer the Mighty, at your service."
Joxer is a wannabe soldier who accidentally
falls in with Xena and Gabrielle,
who tolerate him in spite of his eternal
incompetence. Joxer eventually falls in
love with Gabrielle, who briefly returns
his affections while under a love spell.
But it fades, of course, and Joxer ultimately
marries one of Xena's many lookalikes,
with whom he has many children. Because
that's just how things roll in the Xenaverse.
Ted Raimi has gone on to have a booming screen
career since Xena's end. He's worked as a voice
actor in Code Monkeys and Buddy Thunderstruck,
as well as landing a list of live-action roles on
shows like CSI: NY, Masters of Horror, and Legend
of the Seeker. He also starred in his brother Sam
Raimi's Ash Vs. Evil Dead alongside two of his
Xena co-stars, Lucy Lawless and Bruce Campbell.
But film is where Raimi's career has really taken
off. He's been seen in such blockbusters as all
three of his brother Sam's Spider-Man movies, as
well as The Grudge and The Midnight Meat Train.
Like Xena, Ares began as a Hercules: The Legendary
Journeys character, played by New Zealander Kevin
Smith. Smoldering Ares is a complicated figure
in the Xenaverse — particularly when it comes to
Xena herself. It is Ares that imbues Xena with
her violent warrior spirit, and Ares with whom
she has a complex romance. He's complicated,
stormy, and played to perfection by Smith.
After Smith's time on Xena, he went on
to play the lead role in the TV movie
Lawless: Dead Evidence and a short film called
The Meeting. Smith was also in the 2002 martial
arts fantasy film Warriors of Virtue 2: Return
to Tao but while filming Warriors of Virtue,
Smith took a tragic fall from a prop
tower on the set of another film.
He passed away at the age of 38. His TV movie
Riverworld was released posthumously in 2003,
and is his final film. Had he lived, Smith's
next project would have been the Bruce Willis
action caper Tears of the Sun set to start
filming just one month after his death.
As Xena's nemesis Callisto, Hudson Leick is the
picture of malice. A survivor of one of Xena's
past rampages, she lost her village and her family
to the warrior princess' bloodlust. Over the
course of 18 episodes, Callisto's sole ambition
is to make Xena's life hell whenever possible.
Callisto pretends to be Xena for a while,
committing new horrible crimes in her name to stir
up public hatred. She even dies multiple times by
Xena's hand, but is continually brought back. She
becomes a warlord, a demon, an angel, and even a
goddess over the course of her vengeful journey.
Hudson Leick has had a number of one-off roles
in television shows since her stint on Xena,
including Tru Calling, CSI, Nip/Tuck, Shark,
and Law and Order: LA. She's also been busy
on the film front, booking appearances in
the action thriller Cold Heart, the rom-com
One, Two, Many, and a noirish mystery called Paris
Connections. Recently, however, Leick's career has
undergone a major change. She now works primarily
as a yoga instructor through her company, Healing
Heart Yoga, through which she runs retreats,
teaches classes, and even does astrology readings.
Karl Urban's Julius Caesar is one of Xena's mortal
enemies. Seriously: Their first meeting ends in
him breaking her legs and crucifying her. After
Xena is resurrected, her enmity towards Caesar
grows until she finally kills him once and for all
in season four's "The Ides of March." Even that
isn't the end for Caesar, however — he manages
to take the Fates hostage and rewrite reality by
using their magical loom. Xena saves the day,
of course, but not before being trapped in an
alternate reality in which she and Caesar
rule Rome together as Empress and Emperor.
So what's Urban been up to since Xena
went off the air? The better question is,
what hasn't he done? Urban has had significant
roles in some of the biggest film franchises
of the last couple of decades, including starring
as Eomer in The Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers
and Return of the King, as Bones in Star Trek,
Star Trek Into Darkness, and Star Trek Beyond,
and as Skurge in Thor: Ragnarok. Urban further
expanded his superhero resume as Billy Butcher
on Amazon Prime's The Boys, and had a full-season
arc as Detective John Kennex in Almost Human.
Urban has also played leading roles in Dredd,
The Bourne Supremacy, Doom, and more. He is set
to star in the crime drama Cold Providence, which
goes into production in 2021. Karl Urban might not
actually be Julius Caesar, but it turns out that
he and Caesar share an unstoppable work ethic.
Alexandra Tydings' Aphrodite has a
longer character arc on Hercules,
but the 11 episodes of Xena
in which she appears are still
plenty significant. Aphrodite is
something of a valley girl in Xena,
often used for comic relief and light-hearted
looks into the politics of Mount Olympus.
"Hello? The love goddess is off
the clock. I got my own problems."
Her arc turns horrifying, however, when
her brother Ares dies and she undergoes
a psychotic break. This results in
the total loss of love in the world,
as this emotion cannot exist without
the balance provided by war. Naturally,
Xena comes to the rescue by resurrecting Aphrodite
and Ares, and thus restoring world order.
As a screen actor, Alexandra Tydings has been
fairly quiet since Xena completed its run.
She has had small roles on the 2001 television
show Sheena, modern classic The Wire in 2008,
and a handful of other shows and TV movies. From
2015 to 2016, she starred in a number of episodes
of the documentary series From the Mouths of
Babes, in which she discusses her time on Xena.
She's also worked as an independent writer,
director, and producer on a variety of projects.
The Trial of Hanna Porn, her 2015 look
at the struggle for reproductive rights,
won the Best of Fringe award at the Charm
City Fringe Festival, while Rainbow Bridge,
a short film covering similar themes,
was successfully Kickstarted in 2017.
Many strange characters populate Xena's five
seasons, but Eve has to be one of the weirdest
of them all. Played by Adrienne Wilkinson, Eve is
Xena's daughter, conceived immaculately to serve
as Callisto's reincarnation after she becomes an
angel. Yes, really. Eve is prophesied to be the
"bringer of Twilight," who will end the reign of
the Olympian gods. For a huge chunk of Eve's life,
she is hidden away and/or on the run, eventually
finding protection with her birth mother,
Xena. She later becomes a missionary of Eli,
the Xenaverse's loose take on Jesus Christ.
Actor Adrienne Wilkinson has kept extremely
busy since her 11 episodes as Eve on Xena. She
has done a great deal of voice acting for video
games including Star Wars: The Force Unleashed,
Command and Conquer 3: Kane's Wrath, The Sopranos:
Road to Respect, and Dead To Rights II. Her
television work includes appearances on Undressed,
As If, Angel, ER, Charmed, and Star Wars: The
Clone Wars. She's also had small roles in movies
including action caper Raze, and more recently
appeared in the 2020 horror flick Dreamkatcher.
Wilkinson also wrote, directed, and co-produced
the documentary series From the Mouths of Babes,
in which she interviews many of her Xena co-stars.
As ruler of the Amazons, Danielle Cormack's
Ephiny is yet another fierce and powerful
woman of the Xenaverse. While she starts out
on rocky ground with both Xena and Gabrielle,
over the course of their shared arc, the
women eventually become staunch allies.
Ephiny marries the centaur Phantes,
and names her child Xenan after Xena,
who performs an emergency c-section
during Ephiny's childbirth.
Ephiny is tragically killed in battle protecting
her Amazonian tribe, and avenged by Gabrielle.
Danielle Cormack has added an impressive number
of New Zealand and Australian TV credits to her
name since appearing on Xena. Cormack starred
in young adult fantasy Maddigan's Quest,
the dramedy Rude Awakenings, crime dramas
The Strip and Underbelly, drama The Cult,
action-adventure The Legend of the Seeker,
courtroom comedy The Rake, prison drama Wentworth,
crime procedural Jack Irish, and
rom-com Fresh Eggs. More recently,
she's been working again with her Xena co-star
Lucy Lawless on the crime drama My Life Is Murder.
A master escape artist, Autolycus is characterized
by a list of standout skills and personality
traits that include his deep sense of justice,
excellent disguises, and campy flair. He only
figures in eight episodes, though he has a longer
arc on Hercules, but boy does he make those eight
episodes count. Not only is Autolycus an important
ally to Xena and Gabrielle, he brings a wonderful,
banter-heavy comedy to the show that fans
still relish years after the series' end.
The actor who portrays Autolycus, the legendary
Bruce Campbell, needs no introduction. This star
of the iconic Evil Dead series — created by
Xena co-star Ted Raimi's brother, Sam — has
been a fearsome force in movies and television
for years. Campbell has played significant roles
on Burn Notice, The Replacements, Fargo, and
the title role in Ash vs. Evil Dead. Campbell
has also compiled an impressive roster of voice
work that includes Rapunzel's Tangled Adventure
and Cloudy With A Chance of Meatballs. He also
made a cameo in the 2013 Evil Dead remake…
"Groovy."
...along with a whole host of other
big- and small-screen projects.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.